can you wear a hat instead of sunscreen  first we need to talk about one of the  biggest misconceptions with uv you  actually get more uv from the sky than  directly from the sun if you're standing  in the middle of a field you actually  get less than half your uv exposure from  direct sunlight about 60 is the sky  bouncing uv onto you so if you wear a  hat and it's blocking out the sun you're  taking care of that 40 direct sunlight  you're also getting rid of that circle  of sky right above your head but there  is still that strip of sky all around  that's still reflecting uv onto you  sometimes the ground can also reflect uv  snow is really bad it reflects 50 to 90  percent very white sand can also reflect  up to 40 percent so that's why you can  still get burned in the shade and a hat  is like a very small amount of shade  hats are definitely helpful but if you  can see a lot of blue sky or if you're  moving around a lot then you'll probably  want to wear sunscreen as well